était un peu vexé disons contrairement à
ce que tu me disais non moi j'ai retapé
le boulard non mais il faut que je
réponde
tu me disais que j'avais attrapé le
boulard je pense sont là je suis pas de
repreneur n'a eu d'accord alors oui bon
déjà petite attaque est pas sympa mais
si je me suis posé la question je suis
m'affirmer mais bon je suis entré pas se
lever la grève pour des lui on en fait
je réponds pas du tout parce que
cyril ne m'a pas embaucher de façon j'ai
pas posé mon cv et si demain je vais
avoir le boulard je n'ai pas eu à 20 ans
je n'aurai pas à 41 ans et si
effectivement j'avais le boulard je
pense que je ferai des doigts d'honneur
on serait un spectateur et j'insulte ray
des handicapés est d'ailleurs j'aimerais
te dire une chose vraiment non mais ne
fait pas d'étonner oui ces paraphes cour
d'école en asie mais écoute mon enfant
le truc c'est que à l'époque tu disais
que tu regrettait d'avoir fait des
choses avec cauet forcément et qui a
beaucoup de gens qui sont acharnés sur
toi comme à l'époque avec ce changement
qui est surtout à vis-à-vis de l'it et
vecta eu avec pharrell williams d'accord
et cela même un peu a atteint un
paroxysme que c'est venu un chef chez sa
maman et compagnie j'avais dit que je
reçois des menaces de mort et compagnie
alors maintenant mais toi la place quand
vous vous êtes en train d'envoyer les
gens de télé réalité c'est que moi même
que je cautionne pas sur certaines
émissions parce que ce ne sont pas mes
valeurs de balancer de la bouffe et les
maîtres à jouer à kolontar
c'est d'autant plus que vous avez le
droit de donner un avis critique mais
vous n'avez pas le droit de parce que
toi aujourd'hui tu as une tribune t'as
ton siège c'est parfait mais demain le
jour tu trouveras sur un tabouret et que
effectivement à l'appui no 6 de cyril
les autres ils n'ont pas à cette tribune
là ils peuvent pas se défendre comme toi
tu as plus de défendre vis-à-vis de
pharrell williams au visage mais aussi
les métiers de lui mais c'est ton métier
mais c'est pas ton métier d'insultés
alors jeunesse et la journée une
émission de divertissement où le gentil
mon cerveau je suis content d'avoir vu
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]